Frauen zum Studio weiter Klaus Strunz
unser Bild-Chefredakteur und tv-chef du
hast ganz viel Zustimmung bekommen eben
auch auf der Straße und gleichzeitig
ganz viel Kritik übrigens auch bei uns
im Haus ja so musste es doch sein also
es ist ein Denkanstoß ja es ist ja nicht
so dass jetzt die ganze Welt schon auf
diesen Flüchtlingsstrom guckt aber man
muss jetzt hingucken um sich
vorzubereiten und es ist klar dass das
dann eine große Debatte auslöst nicht so
klar finde ich dass man dann also wie
eigentliche ist auch schon eine
Gewohnheit sofort ins ganz rechte Lager
als Menschenfeind
bezeichnet wird und als Hetzer oder noch
schlimmere Sachen das finde ich gehört
in die Debatte nicht rein aber dass sie
stattfindet ist wahnsinnig wichtig und
ich werde auch nicht locker lassen die
jetzt in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
immer weiterzuführen es ist doch schon
klar ich will auch nicht dass jemand
hungert und friert aber ich will auch
nicht dass Rentner in Deutschland
hungern und frieren und ich will auch
nicht dass die Kinder von Leuten hungern
und frieren die ein kleines Einkommen
haben oder ein mittleres Einkommen oder
sogar ein Mittel historisch Einkommen
aber jetzt zwei und 300% mehr für ihre
Energiekosten zahlen müssen und dann mal
lieber zu Hause kalt lassen ich mache
mir sogar sorgen dass das zu ganz großen
Problemen führt dass die Selbstmordrate
steigt und ich bin auch nicht der
Einzige der sich darüber Sorgen macht
denn es wird ja jetzt hinter den
Kulissen in der Union schon darüber
diskutiert in der SPD und bei den Grünen
wird es eher tabuisiert weil es nicht
ins Weltbild passt und das finde ich in
der Debatte auch so interessant die
Kritik von links ist natürlich besonders
ätzend und besonders scharf und
besonders überzogen weil jeder der
sozusagen einer
linksliberalen oder linken Ideologie
sich verschrieben hat doch in den
letzten sechs Monaten begriffen haben
muss dass er an naive Träume geglaubt
hat denn alle drei wichtigen Bereiche
die von links immer als
Selbstverständlichkeit
beschrieben worden sind als Lebensziel
als nur so kann eine Gesellschaft gut
leben sind doch zertrümmert also es ist
zertrümmert dass man ohne Waffen leben
kann denn dann kann man sich nicht
verteidigen das setzt halt auf dem
naiven Weltbild an dass er nie eine
angreift das zertrümmert also liefert
die Linke grüne Außenministerin voller
Inbrunst jetzt Waffen das natürlich eine
Niederlage für linke das die zweite
Überzeugung ist dass man keine Kernkraft
braucht zertrümmert es wäre schön wir
hätten noch mehr Atomkraftwerke um jetzt
durch die Krise zu kommen stattdessen
nehmen wir den Atomstrom der umliegenden
Länder so was Verrücktes gibt es ja
überhaupt nicht auch zertrümmert und
jetzt mit diesem Thema der illegalen
Einwanderung zertrümmert sich auch noch
der dritte Lebenstraum nämlich dass eine
Welt existiert ohne Grenzen no borders
wo alle also ich hört irgendwie John
Lennon singen ja imagine dieser
Lebenstraum schön finde ich auch toll
aber halt naiv und hat mit der
wirklichen Welt nichts zu tun da geht es
um Sozialkassen und aus den Sozialkassen
sollen doch bitte die das Geld kriegen
wie es einbezahlt haben wir wollen dort
einmal hinschauen an die Balkanroute
Millionen Menschen die nicht wissen wie
sie ihre Heizrechnung eben zahlen sollen
während ganz viele andere eben die
Rechnung vom Staat bezahlt bekommen
Hartz-IV-Empfänger und Flüchtlinge und
unser Reporter Maximilian tabaczynski
ist dort an der Balkanroute und wir
wollen einmal schauen wie dort die Lage
ist wie viele Flüchtlinge sind denn
gerade hier auf dem Weg und ja wie geht
es Ihnen
was auf Deutschland zukommen könnte das
merkt man hier hier ist ungefähr heute
schon 150 Flüchtlinge in dem Park direkt
am Prager Hauptbahnhof das ist die
letzte Station im Endeffekt bevor es
dann Richtung Westeuropa geht wir haben
mit Flüchtlingen reden können die
meinten in Serbien sind zum Beispiel
schon 10.000 Flüchtlinge die nach Europa
und Westeuropa wollen also die quasi
auch das wird sich wahrscheinlich in den
nächsten Tagen auch noch mal verstärken
wir müssen jetzt weiter sehen wie es
dann eben weitergeht was sagen die
Menschen die als Ziel also wollen die
alle zu uns nach Deutschland wir haben
ja auch mal was gehört von
flüchtlingsverteilung innerhalb Europas
naja also Hauptziel ist bei vielen
Deutschland wir wollen nach Frankfurt
die wollen nach Stuttgart nach Berlin
dort haben sie teilweise auch schon
Verwandtschaft aber einige sagen auch
sie wollen nach Belgien und in den
Niederlanden so ist die Lage danke Max
dabeizinski unser Bildreporter an der
Balkanroute in Prag und bei uns im
Studio Klaus Strunz weiterhin unser Bild
Chefredakteur also die
flüchtlingsverteilung die findet
zwischen Berlin Frankfurt Stuttgart
statt und nicht zwischen Tschechien
Polen Deutschland Frankreich genau das
hat sich also schon rumgesprochen keiner
will nach Schweden weil dort
schwierigere Einreisebedingungen sind
keiner will nach Dänemark weil dort
gesagt worden ist hier kommt keiner mehr
rein der nicht wirklich einen Asylgrund
hat keiner will also in die
nordeuropäischen Länder im Prinzip
wollen alle zu uns warum weil wir das
Beste Sozialsystem haben darauf kann man
ja auch stolz sein aber dann muss man es
auch beschützen das ist das was mich so
verrückt macht wir haben ein tolles
Sozialsystem es wurde auch vorhin gesagt
wir sind ein Sozialstaat wir können
wirklich auf ganz viele Menschen
aufpassen und ihnen helfen wenn sie
ihnen schlecht geht aber gerade weil
wird das ja bewahren wollen dürfen wir
nicht jeden reinlassen vor allem nicht
diejenigen die gar kein Recht haben zu
uns zu kommen und Verteilungsschlüssel
ist ja eine wunderbare Sache das ist ja
quasi ein doppelter doppelmorks ja in
Europa funktioniert ja nicht aber er
funktioniert auch in Deutschland nicht
denn wenn ich alles richtig verstanden
habe kommen die Menschen in Deutschland
ja jetzt zum Beispiel auch in Sachsen an
und bleiben dann da weil sich 12 der 16
tollen föderalistischen demokratischen
Bundesländer weigern an dem
Verteilungsschlüssel mitzumachen naja
also da warte ich jetzt aber auch schon
mal von der Bundesregierung dass sie da
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
durchregiert und was mir besonders auf
die Nerven geht und es muss mit dem
heutigen Tag eigentlich Schluss sein und
ein bisschen habe ich auch das Gefühl
dass mit angestoßen zu haben mit einer
deutlichen mit einem deutlichen Verweis
auf das Thema das Politiker endlich
aufhören besorgt zu sein sie sollen
Handeln ich höre mir von jedem Politiker
von Frau Feser habe ich es genau bei dem
Thema Einwanderung noch im Ohr wie sie
besorgt ist über alles ja wunderbar dann
Professor sie sind im Amt sie sind
verantwortlich dann handeln dann nehmen
sie Einfluss auf die EU dann sorgen Sie
dafür dass an den EU-Außengrenzen
kontrolliert wird dann schaffen sie
endlich Asylzentren an den Außengrenzen
wo geklärt wird von deutschen Beamten ob
jemand in Deutschland einen Asylgrund
hat und wenn er den nicht hat dann
bleibt er gleich an der EU-Außengrenze
draußen das kann doch nicht so schwierig
sein so würde jeder normale Mensch
reagieren also lasst uns doch bitte die
Politik auch jeden Tag darauf hinweisen
und lasst uns anregen und lasst uns
fordern und lasst uns noch mal fordern
und noch schärfer fordern dass hier
einfach eine Innenministerin ihren Job
macht
[Musik]